hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 170 something
right 170 170 on the nose wow that's
quite a thing
on the nose and here we are we are back
after a week away uh in The Amazing Sun
so yes
um I'm Dr Brett Weinstein this is Dr
Heather Hein and we've already said it's
the Dark Horse podcast so where are we
headed where we headed well I think um
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
Sun today
um in Natural Selections this week I
wrote about near infrared radiation and
uh and and some of its benefits that we
are coming to understand so I want to
just talk a little bit about that and
then all in service of Earth day which
is today so I have a few excerpts to
share birthday is today Earth days I
thought every day was Earth Day
no all right all right I've heard that I
I did not check my source but uh that
has been I've been told that yeah yeah
although were that the case we'd
probably be treating the place better
yeah I don't I don't see any evidence
that we would be but um because we're
not right right so uh it is Earth Day
today and uh I'm gonna share some
excerpts from this fabulous book The
unsettling of America culture and
agriculture by Wendell Berry first
published in the 70s and uh
prescient and unfortunately as he writes
in the afterward to the Third Edition in
um just as true then and now just as
true today as it was when he first wrote
it so we're gonna use that as a jumping
off point to talk about some of the
things uh that we really ought to be
doing if we were in fact honoring Earth
on uh on this day a day named for it I
guess and on every day and then there's
a couple other little little things we
might talk about what the heck is the
Biden Administration doing with
mortgages
um MIT just dropped his coven mandates
uh we might we might we might get there
but yep so
little things also but mostly
Earth Day what does that mean why do we
like to celebrate it and then not do
anything that actually makes it look
like we either understand or give a damn
about it so that's that's part of where
we're going today all right all right uh
so before we do though some some
housekeeping up front we're going to do
a q a this week uh we will uh be back
again next week we will not do a q a so
we've got a little bit of an unusual
schedule happening right now but this
week we're going to talk to you guys at
you guys for a little while take a break
and come back with a q a you can ask
questions at darkhorsesmissions.com
um I encourage you always to go check
out Natural Selections where I write
weekly and we'll be talking a little bit
about what I wrote there this week again
with regard to the uh near infrared
radiation we have a store where you can
get merchandise
darkhorsestore.org lots of cool pins and
stickers and shirts and backpacks and
and other other awesomeness we have in
fact I have a short excerpt indeed from
our book as well and talking about Earth
Day hunter-gatherers Guide to the 21st
century this is the first time we've
seen it where it says New York Times
bestseller even though that happened
within days of publication so
um you know it only took a year and a
half
to be revealed on the actual covers of
finelyconut yes they have finally cut up
uh but there are signed copies uh here
in the islands where we are and not
everywhere you can't just like come to
the San Juan Islands and be like hey I'm
looking for my signed copy but at
darvel's on Orcas Island not just signed
but signed by us yes
signed by orcas maybe you know it could
be a lot of people but in this case
despite the odds it was actually it was
actually us and as it turns out orcas uh
being notably deficient in fingers uh
that aren't encased in fleshy
protuberances uh don't do a good child
signing books yep and they get them
really sloppy and you and sometimes they
eat them even if you're not real
familiar with Orca morphology you can
detect that they do not have fingers by
the absence of reports of strangulation
of their trainers yes yes yeah they they
will Splash them with their tails
perhaps but then no no strangers there
is apparently one orca who just had
enough and went after their I think four
cases of uh death by orca and three of
them are one particular animal that
that's really yeah I believe that's
correct I hope I hope I'm not repeating
an apocryphal story but I believe that
is correct and actually I guess this was
like I'm fed up I'm done I'm a good ARCA
but I've had enough or was this a
psychopathic Orca no no I don't think
this is a psychopathic look at if you
certainly they exist you put me in the
equivalent I understand swimming pool
for the rest of my life I might start
going after you yeah you'd be put more
in more like a you know a cage 10 feet
square allowed just to Pace back and
forth if you did it for no reason you
just sort of plucked me out of the wild
and dropped me in there in that case I
would not feel that it was psychopathy
coming forth it was just you know pretty
much had it sure I'm just saying it's
it's possible that that was a
psychopathic workout yes and I don't you
know that we may be talking about I
think it's just something that's not
it's real patient Orca the rest of them
are far too patient really apparently
yes speaking of Earth day like everyone
else all the other species out of you
know rise up and say we've had enough
well you know occasionally elephants do
this too you know and for great reason
when you realize you know
babies captured in front of their
parents parents killed in front of The
Offspring all of this stuff you know
three and the elephants at some point
are like you know what you know what
clear to us why we're still playing nice
with you people yeah because you're not
good people and maybe you're good people
maybe you're the best at what people
brings in which case why are we paying
attention to any of you yeah yeah
then there's of course have you seen
this video of um I believe it's a beluga
whale returning somebody's phone that
they dropped off the side of a boat
and again lacking hands how did the
beluga whale pull this off I have not
tear it in its mouth oh and uh so on the
one hand this seems like oh that's very
compassionate on the other hand it's
possible given the effect of cell phones
on people that he was trying to kill
somebody yeah and didn't want uh the use
of cell phones to be picked up
culturally in beluga whale land right he
didn't want suddenly the negative
effects of cell phones on human
civilization to decrease as a result of
dropping them off boats and no no I'm
saying the other side of this which is
that the cell phone left in the water
might then uh spread uh as a thing that
beluga whales were actually engaging in
using I missed what you had said but
you're absolutely right that it is
possible that it was just a safety
measure
yeah yeah
so and again
um I don't know if either of these
stories you've told us here today are
true or not we're going to find out
I don't think we will because I'm not
going to chase it down I don't think you
will either no no it's it's in the
comments which I'm not supposed to read
but sometimes I do okay
um
we are supported by you and after that I
don't you know why you know
wow all right please continue to support
us in spite of what may have just
happened no we're we're good it's it's
fine it's
I'm not gonna lie to you it's not all
good it's never been all good it's never
going to be all good but uh we're gonna
be fine we're gonna no it's also not
gonna be fine
right here yep with our beautiful
Turkish rug behind us
um
it's good our delightful Turkish truck
do you even know what it is
Turkish delicious Delight it's a
desserty thing I remember having it once
and being a little disappointed but in
Turkey when we were in turkey or yeah
yeah really I don't remember having it
there you don't no and we were on our
honeymoon so I think we were mostly
experiencing things together yes we were
yeah no I believe I will have to look up
what it was and see if that's a false
memory or if I remember you from
somewhere else but I believe I have had
Turkish delight I think it was in turkey
and if you're not sure it was delightful
okay
um yeah we're going all over the place
today we appreciate you subscribing to
uh to however it is that you are
encountering our content be it on a on a
YouTube or Odyssey main Channel or a
clip on the clips Channel or on Spotify
or apple podcasts or wherever it is that
you hear or watch us uh consider
subscribing liking uh those episodes and
clips that you enjoy and sharing them
with people who you think would get
something out of them and uh you can
also support us by joining us on either
of our patreons where at both of them
you can join our Discord Community where
you can have conversations with a wide
variety of people on a wide variety of
Topics in a lot of different formats
from book clubs to karaoke and at
Brett's patreon he does two monthly
conversations on the last no the first
Saturday and Sunday of every month and
um at mine you get a month access to a
monthly private q a which is small
enough that and it's the two of us that
we actually are able to engage with with
the chat and usually that's on the last
Sunday of the month but this month
because we are not going to be here next
Sunday we're doing it tomorrow so the
questions have already been asked but uh
if you want more after today if you were
just hungering performing uh you can
join us at 11AM Pacific tomorrow Sunday
March April 23rd and then we leave that
up in case you want to watch but can't
uh can't join us live
uh let's see and of course we have
sponsors uh who we appreciate greatly
and we always start these live streams
the top of the hour three and only three
ads and then don't have any more
throughout you can always tell if we're
reading sponsored content again we're
very Discerning though so we only read
ads for sponsors that we really do
believe in but there's a there's a sound
that precedes and ends the ads and
there's if you're watching that green
perimeter around the outside that's how
you know that we're now reading
sponsored content yeah it's sponsors
that we believe in or I would imagine we
could end up reading something if
somebody threatened our children right
that would be persuasive people would
understand why we did it
not suggesting this I'm just
fleshing out the whole solution set of
reasons that we
perhaps giving people ideas
one of them's right here you know our
children yes I noticed them over there
earlier um
how about our first doing some coffee
excuse a little all right
um
well our first sponsor Heather is uh
mind Bloom that's shocking mind Bloom is
a leader in at-home ketamine therapy
offering a combination of scientifically
robust medicine with clinically guided
support for people looking to improve
their mental health and well-being if
you or someone you love is struggling
with mental health issues those issues
May Loom large in your life
there is no one-size-fits-all solution
but you know that you and your loved one
need something that will help achieve
real and a real and Lasting breakthrough
maybe it's time for you to check out a
guided ketamine Therapy Program from
mind Bloom mind Bloom could be your next
and most successful chapter in mental
health and well-being mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience to begin take mind
Bloom's online assessment and schedule a
video consult with a licensed clinician
to determine if mind Bloom is right for
you if approved you will discuss your
health history your goals for mental
health treatment with your clinician to
tailor your mind Bloom regimen
mindbloom will send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only four
sessions 89 of Mind Bloom clients
reported improvements in their symptoms
of depression and anxiety
reports one client on their site quote I
thought I was broken now the light
inside me is growing stronger every day
let mind Bloom guide you into a better
chapter of mental health and well-being
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first succession program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use
the promo code Darkhorse at checkout go
to mindbloom.com
darkhorsepromocode Darkhorse for a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program today that's mind
bloom.com slash Darkhorse use the promo
code Darkhorse
second sponsor today is Maddie's
all-time favorite and she is barely
visible behind my can't even figure
which way to Pivot she's fairly so you
can see a little bit of blondness back
there behind me
um she doesn't know yet that we're
talking about Sunday so I'm gonna
whisper so I wake her up right this is
her all-time favorite sponsor for good
reason because they make food for her
this is Sundays they make dry dog food
when they approach us about being a
sponsor a while ago now we were dubious
Maddie that's the dog is Labrador Labs
will basically eat anything which you
know if you've ever met a labrador
except for people they're like the
nicest animals in the world but if it's
at all remotely like food they're in
there's a good clarification yeah
they're so gentle yes not eating people
no definitely not what possible
difference therefore was she gonna show
she's like she's the opposite of
discerning it seemed to us was she going
to show an interest between her usual
kibble and we were we were spending
money on her you know we were paying for
top quality
um you know high-end brand kosher kibble
not kosher at all but um and some days
laughs
we were wrong especially him
wow okay yes we were wrong I recall
being yeah we were wrong uh Maddie loves
the food that Sundays makes okay so far
that doesn't distinguish it from any
other food because she just loves food
right but no she really loves this food
she has even sometimes now become
Discerning I'm not going to say she's
always Discerning because sometimes
still you put anything in front of her
and she's like yep it's food I'll eat it
but if she's been having Sundays and
then you put the old kibble in front of
her sometimes she sits her butt down and
looks at you and gives just the saddest
look and as if to say I thought you
loved me right and uh if we haven't in
fact run out of Sundays which was our
excuse one time and one time we thought
well we still have this other stuff
we'll just give you the other stuff and
we fixed it I'm like okay we'll not give
you the high-end kibble that we already
bought we'll give you the Sundays and
boy was she happy uh she um
monster Sundays guess what it's also far
better for her it's not like junk food
and she just thinks it tastes great in
the moment and then she feels terrible
afterwards it's far better for her than
the standard stuff which is basically
burnt kibble that comprises most dried
dog food Sundays is the first and only
human grade air dried dog food combining
the nutrition and taste of all natural
human grade foods with the ease of a
zero prep ready to eat formula Sundays
is an amazing way to feed your dog and
in a pinch a person too we know because
you tried it I did yes Best I Ever Had
low bar on account of the only dog food
that you were ever in any way uh
compelled to try to try right right so I
mean that says something right there
um best is a low bar given that it's
only
it is but actually it really like I
wouldn't I wouldn't put any of the
kibble in my mouth I'm sure I'd be fine
if I did but it just would it would be a
traumatic experience in this case it was
not yeah yeah exactly not that I have
but I but I hear you yeah Sundays is
easy for us humans too no fridge no prep
no cleanup no gross wet dog food smells
and your dog is super happy with you
Sundays is gently air dried and ready to
eat in artificial binder synthetic
additives are General garbage seriously
look at the label on this stuff all of
Sunday's ingredients are easy to
pronounce and healthy for dogs to eat in
a blind taste test Sundays outperform
leading competitors 42-0 sounds like a
made-up number but here's the thing when
I have a bowl of I've already talked
about this she is enthusiastic for any
food but she is way more enthusiastic
for Sunday she bounces and Spins and
leaps in anticipation spin being one of
the only tricks that we taught her young
and she still does it whenever she
thinks we want her to do anything she
starts with a spin and then waits for
further instruction so she spins when
you're holding a bowl of Sundays and
like anticipation uh do you want to make
your dog happy with her diet and keep
her healthy try Sundays we've got a
special deal for our listeners receive
35 off your first order go to
sundays4dogs.com Darkhorse or use code
Darkhorse at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog
you know they're blind tasted
did they blind the dogs well maybe they
used blind dogs and I'm wondering if
blind dogs have seeing eye dogs because
why wouldn't they I think blind dogs are
seeing our people
interesting all right yeah I'd buy that
not trained as such but uh effectively
trained as such
Maybe
our final sponsored this week is Vivo
Barefoot who makes shoes that are made
for feet everyone should try these shoes
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be vivos however are
made by people who actually know feet
they've met feet they've talked to
defeat they have feet of their own they
use that knowledge to make a really
excellent shoe where it is spreading
we've been asked by strangers at the
shoes we are wearing are as good as
they've heard and yes they are
indeed there here at Darkhorse we love
these shoes they're beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there are
no pressure points forcing your feet
into oppositions they're fantastic our
feet are the products have millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run barefoot
cats don't get any shoes though none for
them even if they yell about it modern
shoes that are overly cushioned and
strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a Health crisis people
move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
Vivo Barefoot has a great range
of Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're a certified B
Corp that is pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild in it go to Vivo
barefoot.com and use code Darkhorse 15
to get an exclusive offer 15 off
additionally all new customers get a
100-day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do if by chance
you don't and we really don't think
that'll happen but you can return them
within 100 days and get your money back
that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com use code darkhorse15
at checkout
all right all right
[Music]
today
let us talk first
about so I'm looking for the cat who was
yelling there I don't know where he's
disappeared to and what kind of trouble
he's making about yeah it's just he
wants shoes I think
yeah
um
so for as I mentioned for Natural
Selections which is my sub stack this
week I I did a dive into uh near
infrared radiation and we've talked
about that a couple of times here on
Dark Horse and I did at the end of my
Natural Selections post I linked to the
three places that we've talked about
some of the benefits of sunlight and a
couple other places where I've written
about it before in Natural Selections
the benefits of being outside the
benefits of fresh air vitamin D a little
bit about
um what seems to be the case that
um
melatonin that we hear about which is
generated by the pineal gland
is circulating melatonin and that's what
we hear about that's what we're taking
these supplements some people at night
to help them get to sleep but it seems
to be the uh less the less important the
less common kind of melatonin in our
bodies and that is to say the Melatonin
that is produced by our pineal glands
and which is called circulating
melatonin in fact more of the Melatonin
that we have and there are a couple of
other minor sources but the majority of
melatonin it seems that we are
generating by our bodies is in the
mitochondria in what's called
subcellular melatonin and what prompts
the mitochondria to make subcellular
melatonin is near infrared radiation and
near infrared radiation is coming from
the Sun in fact approximately by many
estimates 70 percent that's seven zero
percent of the photons uh that hit your
body from the Sun and not just yours but
mine too and yes and all the all the
peoples and the cats and everything
about 70 percent of the photons uh that
are hitting you are in the near infrared
part of the spectrum so uh that means
that visible ultraviolet middle and far
infrared and everything on the outside
of those of you know to you know to the
outside of ultraviolet and the outside
of infrared
um all of that is comprises 30 of the
photons and near infrared just off the
red end of of what we call the visible
spectrum because we got to name it and
it's our visible spectrum
are these near-infrared photons and they
are unique uh in many ways and one of
them is that they go pretty deep into
tissue and in fact the
um the cerebrospinal fluid which is the
fluid in your central nervous system in
both the interstices of your like the
ventricles of your brain and running
also down through your spinal cord the
cerebral spinal fluid seems specifically
adapted to reflect near-infrared photons
deep deep deep into your brain such that
the Deep crevices of your brain the gray
matter of your brain are actually bathed
in sunlight Not Invisible light it's not
it looks dark in there but they've got
these near-infrared photons and
everywhere that near infrared photons
get to the mitochondria appear to be
prompted to make subcellular melatonin
which in turn is
exclusively powerful antioxidant and
just a general sort of cleaner upper of
all sorts of detritus that happens
because of normal metabolic processes
all right so I'm going to slow you down
here and just figure out whether I
understand the basics basically let's
geek out a little bit on the science
here yep near infrared is outside of the
human visual Spectrum yes it penetrates
deeply in a way that light does not and
this actually is intuitive because
infrared is heat as far as our
experience and you can imagine that if
you pointed a warm Source if you pointed
a hair dryer at uh at your skin that it
would penetrate more deeply than light
the light I mean light you know very
bright light can penetrate your finger
you can see a flashlight through your
finger but
um but in general you would expect light
to die off very quickly near the surface
and heat to go a little bit farther so
neuron for red and heat art synonyms but
I think the analogy holds and I I will
say actually just show my screen here
for a minute Zach or for a little bit so
this is this is the post it is dark
inside your head but even there the sun
does shine and um I'm going to read the
first couple of actually I'll just read
the first goal of bits because and then
I'll show the Spectrum
your thoughts are born in darkness all
the biology and chemistry and
electricity that comprise your brain
exist in darkness visible light does not
pass through your scholar into your
brain the motor message is going out
move that go there and the sensory
messages coming in smell this feel that
occur in darkness so too to Reflections
on the past predictions of the future
plotting and planning analysis and logic
storytelling and imagining all happen
where the sun doesn't shine except that
last part is not actually true it is
dark inside your head but even there the
sun does shine so again the visible
spectrum of which here we have
um
can you imagine you know everyone has
been through probably elementary school
has has seen this uh where the visible
spectrum and again that's so named only
because it is our visible spectrum uh
there are plenty of organisms that see
into the ultraviolet and others that see
into the infrared but our visible
spectrum is named because we get to name
it because we're the ones with language
and so it's the visible spectrum even
though it's just our visible spectrum is
this tiny band in the middle of the
entire electromagnetic spectrum and uh
off to the short wavelength and you have
ultraviolet off the Violet end and off
to the long wavelength end you have you
have infrared and infrared on this
graphic is just one big block but the
closer to Red you are is that's the near
infrared and you get into medium
infrared and far infrared okay so a
couple things one your point about we
named the Spectrum that's why we call it
visible there are creatures that
perceive into the infrared and there are
creatures that perceive into the
ultraviolet so it is not inherently the
limit of of these kinds of perceptions
and I've read about that's something
here too yep
um okay melatonin yes circulating
melatonin is functioning as a hormone
yeah okay so hormone I'm just gonna fill
in some details let me just say no one
of the things I learned which maybe for
me the most staggering it might be
really exciting to you too it might be
really boring to most people who don't
care about phylogenetics much but that
apparently the so melatonin is ancient
like billions of years ancient like a
like maybe the oldest uh molecule that
is now used as a hormone that exists
okay and far older than vertebrates
farther than animals even and its
original function is as an antioxidant
that the hormonal function is a ladder
uh an add-on function the cam later
okay now this is gonna
force me to stretch into a realm where
I'm not expert and may get something
wrong but a I don't think it's terribly
surprising that melatonin which we
experience or we understand best as a
hormone which is related to the
induction of sleep
is connected to some very ancient
pathway some pre-animal pathway because
the Earth being a place where you have
these two very different phases every
day
um a a molecule that is involved in uh
something which varies based on whether
it's night or day would be adopted into
this uh this highly complex pathway in
in higher animals well and the um in
part uh what what I'm learning and
reading some of the scientific
literature on this is it's a mistake to
think of melatonin as a hormone of sleep
that circulating circulating melatonin
from the pineal gland is associated with
darkness and then subcellular melatonin
associated with the mitochondria
prompted by being bombarded by
near-infrared photons is associated with
daylight and wakefulness and so it is
helping and train our circadian cycles
for sure but in fact if we are not
exposed to near-infrared light to near
infrared photons then we will have a
much harder time getting entrained and
and a having subcellular melatonin
having antioxidants the most powerful
antioxidants we have cleaning up a bunch
of the detritus in our cells which is
likely to make us less healthy and it
will also make it more likely that the
pineal gland is going to have to work
overtime to get enough circulating
melatonin produced because it's it's
supposed to be is some of the thinking
now the pineal gland is basically
supposed to be doing like backup like
let's let's just produce a little bit
more when all the Melatonin produced in
the mitochondria during the day can't
quite get you through the night
and uh if if
what we have done is for you know for an
entire evolutionary history we were
outside we were expected to be bathed
and near infrared light all day every
day
and we came inside but we still spent a
lot of time outside and we still had
campfire so the sun emits near-infrared
radiation the moon Moonlight emits near
infrared radiation fire emits near
information radiation is bounced off the
mountain it's bounced off the moon
exactly it's not generating its own
campfire fire fire of All Sorts
Candlelight is generating near-infrared
radiation incandescent light bulbs a
much smaller amount you know the sun is
the major producer and uh and I actually
don't know Moon versus campfire I assume
campfire is actually producing more than
than you know mostly uh the Moonlight
would but
um even sitting inside by candlelight at
night you get so near infrared radiation
and that will help you your body know
what to do and entrain your Cycles or
sitting with an incandescent bulb but
what doesn't emit any nearered radiation
at all is fluorescent bulbs or the LEDs
that we currently have and this is not
due to technical technology the
limitations we could be but we are not
because once again the reductionism and
the hubris of modern scientism has said
ah
light is what we see by and therefore
the only thing that light is is what we
see by and so what I will do as the
creator of a product is I will create
something uh that and maybe I'll even
call it full spectrum because it's full
visible spectrum
but it doesn't these these so-called
full spectrum bulbs that we are seeing
now
um only are full visible spectrum they
don't go into the near infrared at all
which means if you were inside all day
and you have no incandescent lights you
don't have a fire in your fireplace you
don't have candle lights uh you are
getting almost no infrared radiation at
all and to the degree that you are not
healthy and you're probably not healthy
that may be a major cause
interesting so I do you know want to
give the manufacturers of these things
they're due I don't really want to give
the manufacturers of fluorescence
they're due because my sense is we were
all sold a bill of goods fluorescence
are wonderfully electrically efficient
but they are not green never were green
the mercury in them makes them dangerous
they never should have been released and
they they you know have an oscillation
right like almost no one no thinks that
they are doing well under Florida they
are way too cold yeah they are full of
mercury you break one
you're Distributing mercury in your
house uh anyway they're bad bulbs LEDs
have potential but in some sense the it
is the it's not even that people think
that the visual spectrum is all that
matters it's the the market is
effectively looking for how many lumens
you put out and that's the measure we
use right that's right now like lumens
and temperature like increasingly some
Savvy consumers think oh I'll also look
at temperature still not enough right
and in fact I've been obsessed with the
temperature
forever right because the LED bulbs that
you buy on average are also way too cold
right and they say deceptive things like
daylight and that's really a very cold
light and so anyway you know it's very
hard to buy them the higher the color
temperature number the colder the light
so you're actually looking for
2700 is somewhere in the neighborhood of
tungsten and it's very hard to get
anything warmer but even so it's only
visible spectrum so that may make you
feel like okay I'm not I'm not living in
a basement here but it's not it is not
full spectrum actually sure of course
not and I would point out that back in
the days when tungsten light bulbs were
effectively all there were or you had a
choice between that and fluorescence
people used to deride the tungsten bulbs
as uh heat generators that happen to put
out some light yep
um so anyway there is this sense and
it's exactly like you know what we've
done with uh uh milk right mother's milk
for babies it's like oh it's food for
babies yeah it is but that ain't all it
is and that's right and with everything
and you know this is this is a recurring
theme in our book too right like food is
not just sustenance sex is not just
reproduction and at the smaller level
you know light is not just what you see
buy milk is you know mother's milk is
not just uh what what keeps the Baby
Alive because it's getting calories and
and you know the macronutrients it's not
just about fat protein and carbohydrates
as easy as that is to measure and to say
and to keep track of and that's part of
the problem is that you know the harder
it the more complex the system the
harder it is to have a simple rubric a
simple rule will say ah I just need to
do this and now I know what to buy now I
know what to think now I can like
Outsource that that thing over there and
be free of having to frankly think for
myself
I mean and it's a particular defect of
uh markets when you Market to a consumer
because you know the consumer becomes
obsessed with the megahertz of the
processor the megapixels of the sensor
the you know number of lumens of the
light bulb right because they there's
something that is maybe the most
fundamental thing you're trying to do
but you're not juggling all of the
trade-offs and actually this is this is
interesting because there's there's like
a
there's a sex difference in terms of
what kinds of simple metrics men and
women tend to be focused on but in both
cases it's still just simple ridiculous
metrics okay yeah maybe Fairfax should
get down off the ladder now
I wish you would stick to the former
that's spelled differently doesn't
matter I don't know what that matters
um okay so
um
with like I'm thinking about with a
computer or a car it's it I remember it
used to be sort of a a joke a way to
dismiss oh oh the woman cares about the
color of the thing and uh the ma and
maybe the size of the screen
um if it's if it's a if it's a computer
if it's a car the color primarily or you
know the interior coverings on the on
the upholstery
um but the you know the man's gonna be
thinking about the size of the engine or
the speed of the processor and like in
and okay granted uh the those maybe
female typical concerns are surface and
don't have
maybe anything to do with the Deep
functioning but by focusing on easy to
measure metrics
more male typical concerns
um are those men can be confused into
thinking that they've got the big
picture and it's not the big picture
it's a bunch of little tiny pieces that
don't actually add up to the big picture
of what is this doing and like what
problems is it solving for me and also
what problems might it be creating
so we of course saw this during covid
too with the obsession over antibodies
right yes you know the immune system is
not antibodies that's definitely an
important component but you can find it
right but you can count it you can talk
about it people know what you're saying
more or less and so anyway it became an
obsession now I I you know I've been a
photographer
since you and I met before in high
school yeah
um
I have watched the competition in uh
camera circles and I've
I've been at it long enough in that case
to have watched a reversal of one of
these really okay yeah and it's pretty
interesting
in the early days of digital right there
was this obsession with megapixels which
at first mattered because the cameras
were underpowered they didn't have
enough
um receptors effectively to render a
good image under anything other than
optimal conditions as the light faded or
whatever they became garbage the human
eye could see that pictures were
so-called pixelated because there
weren't enough of them right that's what
we're talking about yeah I mean you know
under perfect conditions at the right
size
at the right side under poor conditions
the human eye could see what we were we
would refer to as pixelated pictures
because there weren't there wasn't a
dense high enough density of pixels and
not only that that's true not only that
but they were disturbing to the eye the
fact is you're the resolution of your
eye Fades at night right and so we're
all used to looking at things that are
pixelated but the I and the it feels in
a different way the silver on film right
is chaotic and so it breaks up the
patterns whereas the pixelated stuff on
a grid of perfectly regular sensors is
disturbing right it is it is jarring to
see you know what it's like is walking
under those
um grid Street lamps at night when it's
when they're making a pool of light and
so you can actually see it like and
maybe it's coming through foliage like
yeah I am actually now in a video game
and I don't like that because I thought
I was living a life yeah it's exactly
it's exactly like that so anyway at
first there was this obsession with with
megapixels because more megapixels gave
you it obscured that that pixelation and
then it became so gamable right it
became relatively easy to imbue a camera
with more megapixels without actually
improving the image quality or
resolution or even improving the number
of effective pixels right you were just
looking at the number in the sensor
which didn't mean that the processor was
really giving you any benefit for it so
it became a stupid game where more
megapixels seemed good but wasn't
during that time as people were obsessed
with megapixels because they knew what
to ask they were ignoring the most
important things that dictated whether
or not you got good pictures which was
what well the most the biggest one to me
was the latency you hit the button and
how long before the thing actually takes
an image and this matters hugely if
you're photographing anything that moves
because it is really your ability to
catch the instant that the child Smiles
that the animal does the interesting
thing and if you hit that moment and
then it takes a half a second for the
shutter to fire or worse you've lost the
shot and so you know at the very least
you wanted a balance between you know a
lot of megapixels and low latency but
then megapixels came back and became
important again because effectively the
most expensive part of a really good
camera is the glass it's the lenses and
if you had a huge number of megapixels
right then you could use a shorter lens
and you could capture the thing that you
were looking for in the center of your
image and then you could crop in and it
wouldn't break down because there were
enough megapixels that you got the
resolution even when you cut you know 70
of the photo out so anyway I I watched
megapixels go from the thing to ignore
to back to the thing that actually
mattered so that's that's something to
be aware of yep um is that these things
may may invert but the obsession over a
single parameter is no doubt uh
dangerous and light bulbs are an obvious
place where this is maybe even made us
unhealthy I I think
um I think certainly it has I think
certainly it has and you know we've
increasingly people have been talking
about things like blue light filters and
getting you know getting bright blue
light is best from the sunlight in the
morning and getting you know red shifted
light at night but that's still all
within the visible spectrum that's still
all talking about what we can discern
with our actual eyes without without any
Aid and
um you know think about what it actually
feels like to be out in the sun and I
was writing this we were lucky enough to
as you said to be in the in the sun in
this last week and I was
I was able to be out like stand-up
paddle boarding or snorkeling and then
come and you know read about melatonin
and think about this and go I know I
just know
at the like intuitive level how healthy
I feel being out in the sun or we
weren't in a place really where there
was sand we were just in in water but
you know sitting on a hot like sun hot
sand
is actually healing as well because and
this is someone someone wrote this into
the comments on my on my piece and I
looked I was like oh of course Albedo
given what it is dry sand is reflecting
some of that near infrared radiation
back at you and so if you're sitting in
the sun on a beach with dry sand you're
getting the near infrared both you know
from above and From Below as well and
it's you're just like absorbing it and
especially for those of us who live in
the North and are coming out of a you
know a winter feeling sort of pale and
sluggish and without enough sunlight in
us uh it you know we just get we get
greedy for it and I think we don't have
the language we know we know we need to
breathe we know we need to eat we know
we need to drink
we don't know at the same level that we
need this this energy that's coming at a
from a part of the electromagnetic
spectrum that we can't sense directly
but we can actually sense it if you go
out and you just you try to pay
attention granting that we don't have
the language for it try to pay attention
to what it feels like to be on the sun
and know that actually
that's healthy don't respond to that by
going like oh I'd better cover up
although it's also true interestingly
that near-infrared unlike medium and far
infrared or ultraviolet actually goes
through clothing it goes It goes through
your skin it goes through your skull it
goes through clothing uh it could you
know the thinner the clothing lighter
colored the clothing the easier but it
goes through clothing so that you can
actually get it even if you're outside
covered up
um
throws me that it goes through light
colored clothing easier I would guess
the opposite but I and I as I said that
I you know I read that one place and I
thought that seems opposite to me so
that's actually the one thing I just
said where I haven't I haven't I haven't
chased that down because it feels like
black would absorb and then and then but
if it's if it absorbs
um then maybe it doesn't go into your
skin whereas if it's white maybe it goes
through I'm not I'm not totally sure but
thinner rather than thicker clothing
it'll go through more Yep yeah um I
wanted to point out though I don't think
it is in any way that we don't detect
the health benefits of this what I said
was we don't have the language for it we
don't have the language the way we it's
like oh I'm hungry
I crave
sunlight like I I guess but it does we
don't have the language and we don't
have the skepticism of experts right and
the problem is that these sons of
[__] told us
don't tan it's bad for you it's like a
vice right it's a vice you're tanning
because you're vain or something no
actually there's a reason that people
who are tan look healthy and it's
because a tan is not a burn right and it
is a measure of your exposure you know
enough that your cells have actually
detected that uh that light and are
responding by producing protective
melanin yeah don't burn sure yeah we can
all get on that like absolutely
um but you know they told us for however
many decades you know don't tan stay out
of the sun wear sunscreen every time you
go in the sun all of that they told us
during covid you know oh you can't go to
the beach
stay inside I mean they literally told
us they literally told us don't go to a
place where there is I believe literally
zero chance of you couldn't attracting
covet and then at the point that that
became obvious they never said oops they
may have opened the beach but they did
not say yeah you should keep in mind
that experts sometimes get things
completely upside down
that's what they should have said well
they did keep people from skateboarding
so that's something well they should
have just criminalized it finally which
would have made all of those bumper
stickers so ironic
um but the skateboarding is not a crime
sack right
[Laughter]
um but anyway look
the point is you get
ungodly material harm from the belief in
experts who tell you that the height of
health is margarine you know not tanning
words
formula for your babies all of this
stuff and the only soft food for your
babies too once they're off the formula
yeah really you just need it don't make
them work their jaws it's hard for them
yeah and it's also hard on the
orthodontists if you make them work
their jaws because then they've got
nothing to do no ability to pay their
mortgage right and they can't get a boat
so but look if everybody I don't know
what we're doing with kids in school I
don't know what we're teaching them but
we should be teaching them places where
experts have really [__] up and it's
killed people right so that when the
experts say something it's not that the
experts are wrong but you certainly have
to entertain that possibility you
unfortunately do know some of what we're
teaching kids in school and it ain't
that right it's that they the children's
wildest fantasies may actually reflect
reality and that they the children know
better than the adults which is going to
make kids feel really awesome about the
world to know that they at five or ten
know a lot more than all of the adults
who are supposedly in charge well it's
actually kind of a funny uh Paradox
right because what the experts are
telling us is that the children who are
as far from expert as anybody could be
are in fact the experts they are the
experts the experts are telling us the
kids are the experts and so it does it's
like well then we believe the experts in
which case they're wrong which case the
children aren't the experts and that
leaves a complete vacuum of experts well
the experts are behaving like children
which means that they are the ones in
the know the children experts and the
experts experts behaving like children
are
in their naivete recovering expertise
which would be suspect had they not been
childlike
this yes yes yes so this is actually
this is a perfect segue actually
um so it's Earth Day history of Earth
day is long and a little bit silly but
uh it's it's I think it's it's Honorable
in its Origins it started in 1970. uh as
um in part a response to things like
Rachel Carson's uh Revelations about uh
the role that insecticides were playing
in destroying insect
populations and communities and that's
and um and then going up up to birds and
uh you know that continues a pace that
that problem has not gotten better there
were there were advances that we made
actually uh you know we grew up in 1970s
and 80s La where the when the air
quality was incredibly bad like you flew
into LAX in the 70s and 80s and it was
just a it was pea soup it was yellow it
was disgusting and they cleaned that up
yep and um largely I think that was car
emission standards um but uh and you
know at some point mid 70s catalytic
converters and leaded gasoline like you
know let gasoline went away and so that
helped a lot too a ton right and
California being the unusually large
populace and Powerful state that it is
effectively forced that change on the
world I don't know if it was inadvertent
or not but the fact is it didn't make
sense to make two kinds of Cars one for
The Californians and one I mean it did
happen sometimes but very quickly it
made sense just to build cars that put
out less emissions and it makes a huge
difference yep actually I would point
out
one of the ways in which our move from
Oregon to Washington has been a step
down is that Oregon has good emission
standards and it matters the number of
times you find yourself behind some
vehicle belching toxic smoke right is
huge in Washington compared to Oregon
because you actually get penalized for
it you know yearly you can't register
your vehicle yep
um so anyway those standards matter and
we forget about them it's very easy to
gripe about regulations that don't work
but you know it is interesting to bounce
back between these two states which are
actually politically very similar but
have come to opposite conclusions on
that front indeed
um
so I don't want to spend really any time
mocking how bad a lot of modern sort of
environmentalism is we could spend a lot
of time there and I don't think it's all
that helpful but I will say you can show
here my screen briefly exact at
earthday.org in celebration of Earth Day
has a take action watch live earthquake
on Earth Day I and they have six
recommendations on Earth Day I will push
for climate literacy we'll grow trees
will support sustainable fashion will
help end plastic pollution we'll attend
a cleanup we'll vote Earth
so if I may have my screen back if you
click through on those and I you know
I'll link to this in the show notes but
I don't necessarily recommend that you
do a couple of those are honorable help
in plastic pollution yeah we got a
problem we got a serious problem any
Beach you go to at least in the tropics
and apparently the like a large part of
the middle of the Pacific Ocean is just
teeming with plastic we got a big
problem right and that's the stuff you
can see the microplastics is is a bigger
problem probably some of those are vague
others misguided of those those
recommendations on Earth Day which you
see if you click through and like oh I'm
going to vote Earth wait no you have to
vote the way they want you to and it
turns out if you read the fine print
it's not actually going to be good for
the Earth
so I read that and I thought well geez
right away I can see that there's some
big things that are missing from that
um on Earth Day I would like to work or
to work to slow or halt non-reversible
solutions that impact earth and its
inhabitat inhabitants things like
um
stopping or slowing the application of
glyphosate on crops the use of
neonicotinoids insecticides on crops
which again kill the insects and then
the birds that eat them and up and up
and up the food chain I would like there
to be no mRNA on my meat thank you very
much and I'd like roads to be built into
wild deep nature only under conditions
when it is absolutely absolutely
necessary and that was just like the
first four things that came to my head
yeah in terms of like on Earth Day
let's not sign a petition letter let's
be thinking about the actual things that
are happening all the time that are
actually making this beautiful planet of
ours less Beautiful by the day yes I
just want to one correction before our
lame ass detractors come after you
synthetic mRNA you don't want on your
meat sure yes right right okay you could
imagine I don't care like this really
okay not not you but but them yes
um
so um our friend Jacob Shockey who is
the founder and executive director of
the soon to be renamed Beaver Coalition
who um I wrote about some of his work
Natural Selections you did a wonderful
Dark Horse episode with him this is
going to have been in January I think
January February he recommended to me
this book The unsettling of America
culture and agriculture by Wendell Berry
I have not um I've only read about half
of it so far I've jumped around a little
bit but it's it's remarkable it was
published first in 1977.
and um and he's this is a third edition
with an afterward for the Third Edition
written in 1995 so he's he's gone back
to it a few times uh Wendell Berry has
one of the premises is found early in
the book on page eight he writes the
revolution has deprived the massive
consumers of any independent access to
the Staples of Life clothing shelter
food even water
air Remains the only necessity that the
average person can still get for himself
and the revolution is imposed to heavy
tax on that by way of pollution
commercial Conquest is far more thorough
and final than military defeat
so this book is mostly about the value
of Agriculture and farming and
Agriculture and farming as a kind of
ecological and cultural activity that
has been destroyed by a industrial and
business approach to it
uh so let me read a few sections uh for
us to for us to consider here we have in
the chapter
the agricultural crisis as a crisis of
culture
a competent farmer is his own boss
he has learned the disciplines necessary
to go ahead on his own as required by
economic obligation loyalty to his place
pride in his work his work days require
the use of long experience and practice
judgment for the failures of which he
knows that he will suffer
his days do not begin and end by rule
but in response to necessity interest
and obligation they are not measured by
the clock but by the task and his
endurance they last as long as necessary
or as long as he can work he has
mastered intricate formal patterns in
ordering his work within the overlapping
Cycles human and natural controllable
and uncontrollable of the life of a farm
such a man upon moving to the city and
taking a job in Industry becomes a
specialized subordinate dependent upon
the authority and Judgment of other
people his disciplines are no longer
implicit in his own experience
assumptions and values but are imposed
on him from the outside
for a complex responsibility his
substitute a simple dutifulness the
strict competences of Independence the
formal Mastery the complexities of
attitude and know-how necessary to life
on the farm which have been in the
making in the race of farmers since
before history all are replaced by the
knowledge of some fragmentary task that
may be learned by rote in a little while
I would say and I'm sure Barry would not
argue that farming is the only
situation uh that a human being can find
themselves in which involves actually
solving problems as they come and and
knowing the complexities of the
situation but it is an obvious one
crafting things with your own hands also
does this but the move to dependency
which is in large part what a move to
the city is
uh not only makes you dependent on
others for you know your food your water
your everything but it also turns you
into a specialist and to that point here
we have another excerpt from a little
earlier in the book this is from the
chapter called the ecological crisis as
a crisis of character
and this is a longer excerpt
I think it's important
the disease of the modern character is
specialization
looked at from the standpoint of the
social system The Amos specialization
may seem desirable enough the aim is to
see that the responsibilities of
government law medicine engineering
agriculture education Etc are given into
the hands of the most skilled best
prepared people
the difficulties do not appear until we
look at specialization from the opposite
standpoint that of individual persons we
then begin to see their grotesqueery
indeed the impossibility of an idea of
community wholeness that divorces itself
from any idea of personal wholeness
the first and best known Hazard of the
specialist system is that it produces
specialists people who are elaborately
inexpensively trained to do one thing
we get into absurdity very quickly here
there are for instance Educators who
have nothing to teach communicators who
have nothing to say medical doctors
skilled at expensive cures for diseases
they have no skill and no interest in
preventing
more common and more damaging are the
inventors manufacturers and salesman
devices who have no concern from the
possible effects of those devices
specialization is thus seen to be a way
of institutionalizing justifying and
paying highly for a calamitous
disintegration and scattering out of the
various functions of character
workmanship care conscience and
responsibility
even worse a system of specialization
requires the abdication to Specialists
of various competences and
responsibilities that were once personal
and Universal thus the average one is
tempted to say the ideal American
citizen now consigns the problem of food
production to agriculturalists and
agribusiness men the problems of Health
to doctors and sanitation experts the
problems of Education to school teachers
and Educators the problems of
conservation to conservationists and so
on
the supposedly fortunate citizen is
therefore left with only two concerns
making money and entertaining himself
remember this is written in 1977.
he earns money typically as a specialist
working an eight-hour day at a job for
the quality or Consequences of which
somebody else or perhaps more typically
nobody else will be responsible and not
surprisingly since he can do so little
else for himself he is even unable to
entertain himself for there exists an
enormous industry of exorbitantly
expensive Specialists whose purpose is
to entertain him
the beneficiary of this regime of
Specialists ought to be the happiest of
Mortals or so we are expected to believe
all of his vital concerns are in the
hands of certified experts he is a
certified expert himself and as such he
earns more money in a year than all his
great grandparents put together
between stints at his job he has nothing
to do but mow his lawn with a sit-down
lawnmower or watch other certified
experts on television
at supper time he may eat a tray of
ready prepared food which he and his
wife also a certified expert procure at
the cost only of money transportation
and the pushing of a button
for a few minutes between supper and
sleep he may catch a glimpse of his
children who since breakfast have been
in the care of Education experts
basketball or marching band experts or
perhaps legal experts
the fact is however that this is
probably the most unhappy average
citizen in the history of the world he
has not the power to provide himself
with anything but money and his money is
inflating like a balloon and drifting
away subject to historical circumstances
and the power of other people from
morning to night he does not touch
anything that he has produced himself in
which he can take pride for all his
leisure and Recreation he feels bad he
looks bad he is overweight his health is
poor his air water and food are all
known to contain poisons there is a fair
chance that he will die of Suffocation
he suspects that his love life is not as
fulfilling as other peoples he wishes
that he had born been born sooner or
later he does not know why his children
are the way they are he does not
understand what they say he does not
care much and does not know why he does
not care he does not know what his wife
wants or what he wants certain
advertisements and pictures and
magazines make him suspect that he is
basically unattractive he feels that all
his possessions are under threat of
pillage he does not know what he would
do if he lost his job if the economy
failed if the utility companies failed
if the police went on strike if the
truckers went on strike if his wife left
him if his children ran away if he
should be found to be incurably ill and
for these anxieties of course he consult
certified experts who in turn consult
certified experts about their anxieties
uh that's quite the description
especially given the time period 1977.
yeah amazing
so I wanted to uh pick up on a theme
there yeah
you and I have talked about the
absurdity of higher ed which is almost
entirely in the hands of people whose
graduate work was painfully narrow right
and there's no reason
at the point that you are standing in
front of a room of people in their first
college biology course that you want a
specialist at the front of the room you
don't you don't you want a generalist
you want somebody who understands the
integration of all of the various fields
of biology you do not want somebody who
has focused very narrowly on a single
pathway or a single creature or whatever
they might have done
you also don't want specialist making
policy right and that the point is you
can see it with the Educators because it
wasn't always this way right it is the
fusion of research with education and
then the monetary perverse incentives
that cause people a to narrow in the
focus you don't want to invest five
eight ten years in a PhD only to you
know have it not pan out so you
specialize in something so narrow that
it's a sure thing right that that is a
bizarre and stupid incentive we do not
get a good return on our investment as a
civilization for people being driven to
you know invest time in a way that
causes them to answer some question that
couldn't possibly fail right we want
them to take risks and that means some
of those phds wouldn't pan out but
that's not what happens
um so anyway that narrowing
what Barry is pointing out is that the
narrowing the market causes a narrowing
which I think we have to acknowledge
creates a huge amount of wealth in the
narrow sense right the exchange between
Specialists creates a huge amount of
wealth but it may destroy the capacity
of the individuals who have been
specialized to think which is in some
sense what we are suffering from
and that's exactly what we're suffering
from in fact I've got one you'll
recognize this book I do recognize that
but this is this is our book 100
gatherers Guide to the 21st century
evolution of the challenges of Modern
Life here's just two very brief
paragraphs from the beginning from the
first chapter of the human niche
to the question of specialization
which we also revisit in some depth in
the final chapter of the book
this is in a section on campfire which
again is a recurrent theme throughout
the book the value of campfire and this
is before I had thought at all about
neuron radiation even but you just know
campfire is good for you I don't
remember if we talk about in there we do
talk about the value of fire Spectrum
relatives to light bulbs yes um but yeah
especially at night but
um
just as Humanity broke down boundaries
between niches that no other organism is
broken down so too if we broken down
boundaries between individuals that
nothing else is broken down so
thoroughly with regard to niches we are
a journalist species that contains
individuals who are often specialists
a single ancient American may have been
terrific at wayfinding but terrible at
keeping the flame a single modern human
may be terrific at rock climbing but
terribly organizing their files are
excellent with numbers but unskilled in
the baking of bread as a species though
we are supremely good at all of these
things it is connections between us that
allow us to transcend our individual
limitations often focusing on our trade
while being sustained by the specialized
labor of others
at the boundaries between individuals we
consciously innovate and share ideas and
then reify the best and most relevant of
those ideas for the current moment in
the form of culture for Millennia this
magic has occurred around the common
campfire
and this if you're not
if you're taking all of these words very
very literally and narrowly you may
think that that is in contradiction to
what Barry is writing but but no so
Barry is not talking about a solitary
farmer doing solitary farm work because
I see aptly points out that's not how
Farms work that's not what farming is
that farming always was until
agribusiness made it into effectively a
corporate process
about
um families lineages on pieces of land
that they over Generations often best
had come to know deeply in which there
were Specialists within the family unit
and that there were also
um Specialists but in within the
community where someone may have been
better at Barn Building and another
person better at detecting what's wrong
with your chickens you know but if
you're all in good stud with one another
and you have your land and you own your
land and you know your land well and
your land is different from your
neighbor's land even though both of your
land is probably much more similar to it
than is a piece of land 100 miles away
or a thousand miles away or ten thousand
miles away but you know your land well
and you are not alone wolf and one of
the other things that moving to cities
does for people is it not only removes
from them their own agency and
understanding why it is that they're
doing the work they're doing they're
like I have to show up at a certain time
according to the clock
as opposed to the Sun is up I need to go
tend to the cows or it's the middle of
summer and therefore there is work to be
done and I just have to get out there
and do it and it doesn't matter what
time the clock says or how long I've
been at it or if I think I should be
done for the day because I feel like
I've worked enough nope if the work is
done the work is done if the work is not
done the work is not done but this is
done in collaboration with others that
you don't have you don't have solitary
people toiling endlessly on their own in
healthy farming situations
so I would say it raises a question you
know you can obviously if you're
dedicated to sophistry you can push the
idea of generalism or specialization to
uh to the breaking point and the real
question is what's The Sweet Spot and
with respect to Farms
in general Farms have not been all
inclusive right even the farmers you
know this person is specializing on
livestock that person is specializing on
you know vegetables or whatever it is I
think I think most Family Farms if they
were raising animals also had vegetable
gardens but they had vegetable gardens
right but the point is from the point of
view of their relationship to the market
in general there was some degree of
specialization and the question is well
what's the right level and if you let's
put it this way if you push generalism
you and I are generalists and we like
generalists
um but if you push generalism too far so
that you're literally trying to get
everything you end up a jack of no
traits right right track of all trades
pays a cost not being a specialist but a
jack of no trades is worthless right so
you can over generalize and then you can
hyper specialize and I think Wendell's
point which is also reflected in our
point is that the specialization thing
is easily taken to an absurd Point
especially by and this goes back to the
first thing we were discussing by market
forces that's right which are looking
for productivity right how many units
did you produce right and so that
specialization makes what will I put in
the spreadsheet right and yeah that is a
huge fan of spreadsheet it's like you
know I I love the economy of them the
efficiency of them but
you have to be counting the right stuff
some stuff shouldn't be counted and some
stuff is a proxy for the things that you
actually want to have measured and you
can't measure it and you have to
remember when you're working with
proxies and most people don't when they
are yeah and you know this the
spreadsheet does not preclude you from
measuring not only how many units you
produced but how many came back because
they were defective so you know
something about quality control customer
satisfaction right you know so
what you really want are properly
integrative measures you know not how
many you know antibodies did this
treatment produce but did it actually
produce a Improvement in health and
increase in longevity a resistance to
disease that uh manifests in something
uh integrative and I mean I feel like
this is
you know maybe even a bigger theme than
I thought that the
since we began these live streams a
little over three years ago
one of the things we keep returning to
is are you measuring the right thing are
you have you asked the right question
and is the answer that you have had
returned to you or that you're returning
to us meaningful just because it is
numbers associated with it doesn't mean
those are true numbers or that they are
numbers that are in any way meaningful
and if you haven't measured the right
thing if you're talking about antibodies
and are simultaneously informing us that
for the first time in history natural
immunity is meaningless then I'm sorry
your expertise is [__] like we have
every reason to think you don't know
what you're talking about well there is
a
I don't know what to call it probably
internal to the places that these things
are decided there is some name for this
process right some name that they some
euphemism that they use to explain why
they're doing it but pushing you off of
a metric that matters in order that you
obsess over something that they can
control right in other words uh you know
why did we not measure all cause
mortality and figure out what the effect
of covid was and the various treatments
right all cause mortality that sounds
like a measure you could get behind
right does it make me live longer maybe
I'm not interested in taking the risks
if it doesn't right oh it does seem to
make you live longer well then that
might be something worth taking the risk
because in fact the benefits seem to
exceed them right so
yes all of these things are not as hard
as we are now making them out to be for
reasons that are a little obscure I mean
it is
I'm remembering
when I taught animal behavior when I
when I when we were College professors
and I taught animal behavior and I did
it as you know in a way that was
possible to do at Evergreen because it
was full-time programs and so it was
holistic and so it wasn't a four credit
animal behavior class was a 16 credit or
sometimes a year long you know 48 credit
thing in which
students were expected to generate their
own hypotheses students were excited to
generate their own observations from
which they were expected to generate
their own hypotheses and predictions and
then the tests the either the
experimental tests or the carefully
designed observational
um
observational techniques and and and
processes by which they could test their
hypotheses and I taught them enough
statistics that they could then analyze
the data that they collected having gone
out having designed what they would do
having gone out and actually collected
the data and they did literature review
and they wrote up the papers uh
including both the analysis and what
they thought it meant and they gave
talks so all of that which frankly
there's a lot of phds and Sciences out
there who haven't done all of those
steps and my undergraduates did but one
of the things that I love a lot in that
process and um and that I was always
interested to find was maybe the most
challenging not a lot of students just
like got into it right away but a lot of
students had a very hard time and I
think it's a little bit about
mathiologicalness stuff but it's not
entirely it was
figuring out what actually needed to be
measured like the experimental design
part which I I loved like okay now you
have the question that's great you've
come up with a great question you have
good predictions you know how you all
discriminate discern between these two
hypotheses or like it is possible you've
got two alternative hypotheses how will
you discern between them what do you
need to go out and measure what do you
need to observe in those birds or
whatever it is in order to discern
between these two things and that was a
huge sticking point for a lot of people
and for me you know I cared a lot less
if they ended up knowing you know how to
run a t-test or a Cresco Wallace or you
know be do a great literature review or
anything if they could figure out having
characterized truly alternative
hypotheses what they would need to
measure in order to discriminate between
them there it is right there now you
know how to think now you know how to go
out into the world and do and apply that
to anything and anything at the point
that the data comes back and you
actually see a difference between the
two populations and so amazing right
it's really it's like wow and it's like
and you own that like you didn't
Outsource any of that you black boxed
none of that and then you know I also
preferred things like goodness of fit
test for stats like chi-square is like
you can literally do this on the back of
an envelope like you don't actually need
to plug this into any kind of algorithm
and have it go now let me think okay I
call it significant like oh I don't know
is it really like yeah better if you can
do these really simple inferential
statistics where you can actually you
know with one little table of values go
like oh that is as it looks to me
significant
yeah you're demystifying the process
which is so important because I mean
we've just watched civilization go mad
over the fact that people didn't really
know what science even was they they
sort of think they know what it looks
like and that made them very easy to
fool but you know it may not look like
that it could look like you know a
scruffy person in a forest somewhere you
know counting things in a way that you
don't even realize that that's what
they're doing right and you know yeah do
they have an envelope maybe they didn't
need one they could do the stats in the
dirt right yeah and the point is you
either did you either did the science
part writer you didn't it didn't it
doesn't matter at all whether it looked
like you did the science part right
whether you were wearing the right
clothing or had the right equipment or
anything like that if you measured the
wrong thing if you didn't have
hypotheses going in or if you did but
then you measured something that could
not allow you to distinguish between
them you don't know anything more than
you did I mean you may know some more
stuff but you don't know anything
scientifically more than you did and you
can't say I did the science and you may
even know less than that right in fact
um I was listening to a podcast with
John Unitas today it was one of the
most published academics alive and uh
anyway he he wrote a famous paper about
why most published results aren't likely
to be true and the point is okay it's
one thing that there's no information in
them it's another thing that people
think there is that's right right and
that they may be stacking lots of stuff
on top of conclusions that don't make
any sense and this was certainly true in
Psychology but when the the um P hacking
crisis the replicability crisis
arose in Psychology it was pretty clear
that psychology might have a special
version of the problem but it wasn't
going to be limited to psychology it's
anything where every values were you
know currency right which is to say all
of the social sciences and the part of
biology that has replicants yeah that's
statistical yeah
um so yeah like that it's all very good
so very uplifting and uh and and
terrific so we've you know how
on this Earth Day
we should see the role that
specialization is playing and
reductionism and uh the trusting experts
rather than your own self and
Outsourcing everything that might
actually allow you to produce things and
becoming only a consumer like all of
these things are are bad for you as an
individual and also bad for the
community and the Earth
um but there's some other things that
are on that list of you know not usually
necessarily what we think of when we
think of like what's bad for the Earth
well failing to understand Game Theory
so that's my segue to uh what the Biden
Administration did this week with
mortgages right
um which is and this is just yeah this
you can show this this is a article in
um
Newsweek I picked a mainstream source so
that
um so that all y'alls would know that
this is
really what happened uh U.S Biden raises
costs for home buyers with good credit
to help risky borrowers and that's
basically I mean that's that's what it
is
um home buyers with good credit scores
will soon be facing higher mortgage fees
as the Biden Administration seeks to
close the racial homeownership Gap and
get more first time and low-income
buyers through the door
the idea
being that in order to allow for
mortgage rates or mortgage rates are Sky
High of course and to to get them down a
little bit for people who
um haven't yet bought a home who um and
who are a risky investment for banks
it has to come somewhere like there
something's got to give and so instead
of the federal government saying this is
really really important to us so we're
going to figure out a way to maybe you
know send some money over there from us
which I don't think that would be a good
idea either but no they're not even
supplying anything what they're doing is
they're saying
we're going to take the people who have
good credit who are historically exactly
the people that the banks want to lend
to and we're going to jack up their
mortgage rates
and then use that additional Revenue
that's coming from them to help the
people with bad credit get into
mortgages
I have I'm not sure I've ever heard a
stupider idea and it's not the stupidest
idea I've ever heard there are a lot of
equally stupid ideas out there but I
don't think I've actually ever heard a
stupider idea
it's a dumb one it's really dumb and
it's and it's like it's it misses
everything about Game Theory like
everything
I think we are once again at the point
during covid
at some point you and I realized that
there was a very clear pattern
everything that was recommended was the
opposite of crew right
it's an amazing fact it is when you
first of all you gotta really know your
stuff to get everything upside down
right these are experts right I guess
they are they may not be on our team but
wow they certainly seem to really know
their stuff yeah so anyway we're seeing
that in so many different places right
yep and this is just another example
where it's like uh oh my God there's a
virus close the beaches uh what you want
people to go home really yeah especially
if you've got sick ones at home yeah
right Corral people together in a
building where they're not gonna make
vitamin D keep the windows closed right
every bad idea well this it's almost
like something
I know what people will say but the
point is look saboteurs couldn't do
better right they would they would have
to work overtime to figure out the
number of things that we are now
apparently willingly doing to ourselves
either that or saboteurs have somehow
gotten in and are doing it for their own
reasons but that would seem to be the
more parsimonious explanation wouldn't
it at some point when the
chain of authority is feeding you upside
down
insight and backwards advice
and they're actually going to start
penalizing people with good credit
well but I mean look and like apparently
and I I did not go deep on this but I
think I unto it from just a couple of
lame articles I read that people with
variable rate mortgages are actually
going to see their monthly costs jump
for for mortgages they already have yep
if if they got into a mortgage with
decent credit and a decent rate
according to the the modern version of a
decent rate so it's either
sabotage or
it's pandering
if the idea is that the blue team is now
the team of losers
right no I I'm sorry but this is the
logic of the situation I I look I'm just
gonna be I'm gonna be honest okay I
believe that there's a reason that we
never get free of Communism even though
it's a terrible terrible game
theoretically broken idea yeah and the
reason is
competition
breeds all sorts of things it breeds
um a difference in well-being only part
of which is productive right there is
some aspect to which the competitive
economy produces wealth for people who
contribute that's what it's supposed to
do it also produces a whole [__] load of
REM seeking and the people get very
wealthy doing stuff that is not
producing any value and is in fact
destroying value and that's galling
right so that's all true
but it is also true that in a
competitive environment there are people
who will properly calculate that they
don't have what it takes to compete
that's going to be a large number of
people you could imagine you're either
above the median and you have what it
takes to compete and get ahead a little
bit or a lot or you're below and you
just don't have the the goods and in
part you don't have them because
civilization [__] up and didn't teach
you properly right but the point is you
would expect and what Barry is talking
about with regard to the move into
cities where your work is not your work
like you don't you don't have purpose
that is driven by the actual birthday
right you don't have meaning You're
vulnerable because if the slightest
thing changes if you know Chad GPT makes
your job go away there's not some
program that says I will take care of
you that wasn't your fault right so you
know all of those things are going to
cause people to routinely if you are on
the losing side of that median and you
don't have the tools to to get ahead
then the point is well why don't we just
gang up on the people who do and
transfer some stuff okay so if you were
going to become
the team now I don't think the Democrats
are about is it protecting those team
loser is it team mercenary well
it's team con artist because what
they're really doing is they are
servicing their actual constituents
which are very wealthy successful
competitors but they have to win the
power with which to service those actual
constituents somewhere and that means
they have to fool voters they've got to
Pander to voters well enough that they
actually have some power that they can
then monetize and so the point is if
they decide our voting block are people
who are don't have what it takes even
though that may be in large measure
Downstream of them having screwed up the
policy that might have given them what
it takes right right the point is hey if
we punish you know if if we're going to
become become the the team of player
haters
right we're going to Pander to the
people who are into that because they
don't they can't play and again I'm not
blaming people for not having those
skills I don't think that was their
fault but yep it does suggest a reason
why you would continue to see the same
terrible idea emerge again and again and
every time it fails the claim is well we
never tried it for real so let's do that
but no it fails because of the game
theory and exactly so anyway this
strikes me as
if you have terrible credit and you
resent people who don't
then your team is punishing the people
who have good credit ostensibly to help
you and
that would make some sense if what you
were trying to do was con people into
voting you for you just one more time
you know yep
yeah yes I know that's a cynical take on
the other hand it is 2023 and it's hard
to keep up
I wasn't thinking cynical I was thinking
deeply unfortunate truth so I was
thinking uh
one more thing
uh the college the vaccine mandates the
coveted vaccine mandates at Elite
schools are beginning to drop finally
um MIT is so there's a Twitter account
no College mandates which is where I'm
where I'm seeing these and I did go and
check and like yes it's true they
announced this week MIT is dropping its
code mandates but it's um it's mid-april
right
to be effective May 11th right because
the delay that thing again so I just
thought we should talk I don't know
we've talked about this a lot not on
camera but I don't know if we've
actually talked about this
utter insanity
wherein and the minute we were saying
this even in summer 2020 when there was
all this like going back and forth like
oh you know you don't have to wear a
mask you do it very much you do it like
right and it was go back and forth but
they would announce so that was
especially on the west coast like and
when we were still living in Oregon
State at that point like okay in you
know one week from now you're no longer
gonna have to wear a mask in public
stores like one week from now what are
you doing either it's time or it's not
stop it already and the same thing like
MIT so what are they going to do if
someone should like someone is I I don't
know I I think like temper people are
just passing through their campus are
allowed not to be vaccinated uh there
but someone is due for a booster between
now and May 11th and
what they can't come to class they can't
be on the faculty until May 11th if they
don't get the booster like like it just
reveals how
at least a scientific the entire thing
is and I think it's actually not this
thing is not anti-scientific it reveals
that there's just no science there at
all like all of this is coming in the
guise of like the experts with the white
coats and the the vouches and all this
and it's like no actually there's just
just there's no science there yeah it's
it's just nothing it is suggestive of a
process that obviously does not exist
that's brilliant yes it is suggestive of
a process that obviously does not exist
right we're going to put a bunch of
stuff on it it's like these spandrels
it's like they forgot the phrase
effective immediately right effective
immediate that's how you do that right
oh we've changed our mind on masks so
effective immediately you don't have to
wear one yeah right thank you good and
the idea uh this was MIT that dropped it
yeah
so this is the you know the height of
expertise right these are the people
they seem pretty sciency yeah yeah it's
not rocket science well it doesn't
matter if it is because those are the
rocket scientists right the rocket
scientists [__] up covet longer than
anybody else so that they're finally
dragging oh no a lot of the Ivy Leagues
sure but I guess my point is
couldn't the academy be ahead on this
stuff right the academy is supposed to
be the source of insight it's not
supposed to be [__] podcast world but
finally MIT is catching up to what Joe
Rogan viewers knew two years ago this is
nuts
um
in his afterward in his 1995 afterward
to the unsettling of America Wendell
Berry writes
the response to this book has shown that
the universities are not interested in
the pursuit of Truth by argument they're
interested in preserving the conclusion
of an old argument that for the most
part they no longer bothered to make
namely that the world and all its
creatures are machines it's a brilliant
I'm just I've read enough excerpts there
but um like again
from a long time ago yeah there were
people seeing and we were in mid 90s we
were seeing the Brokenness of
universities as well it didn't look like
it does now yeah and there was no woke
to be scraped off the top there was some
at the edges and such but Zachary is
raising his hand as if he's in class are
you might
now I am us I just wanted to mention
someone in the chat pointed out of
course which I think you just forgot to
mention or forgot to bring up that
obedience was effective immediately that
they are perfectly willing to use that
tool when it's on the front end and then
at least in the mandates they will push
it off and see if you're willing to to
follow
brilliant to comply for a little bit
longer but yes when it comes to when the
mask mandates yes come down or anything
it's effective they're very they are
very that's a test they are very eager
to grab control and very reluctant to
give it well and it's even more it's
like the delay it's like where you
really are you really going to comply
because at some level you know during
that period where it's about to drop
there's not going to be a lot of
punishment or anything so it's like are
you really for complying to this in
which case you're going to go right
through the deadline that they have now
set later on or you're gonna stop
complying right when they say it's in
the future
yeah so it I mean it's it's a
it's a way to assess actually
um those who are thinking it through in
terms of like what could the evidence
possibly be that finally allowed you to
you know see reality here or the
distinction being those people and the
like well I just do what I'm told
so the people who just do what they're
told
on the MIT campus presumably have now
heard that they are no longer required
to do X Y and Z
as of a date yet to come
and so they will continue to do what
they've been being told to do for years
now because what they do
apparently what is being taught at one
of the world's Premier engineering
schools is do what you're told
I wonder why we're failing
um this does raise an issue that I
wanted to
to briefly mention a new article in
tablet on Spike protein yeah that does
our friend Clayton Fox exactly yes who
has done an excellent analysis in which
he goes back through the dark days in
which I in particular and Robert Malone
were accused of
spreading misinformation for claiming
the spike protein was cytotoxic on Dark
Horse
and the point is of course Spike protein
is cytotoxic there was nothing bizarre
about that claim at the time yes you
could Marshal a counter argument based
on the fact that the protein wasn't the
identical one in the coronavirus itself
it had been locked open but as I
remember there was research and I could
have to go back but there was research
that came out of in part out of La Jolla
that said that and then you know the
authors of that were like oh but no
maybe not but like like it was actually
in the press release and so like let's
put it this way it was neither you nor
Robert Malone nor us on Dark Horse
um you know we're even postulating we
were we were we were repeating something
that had been published
it was obvious from the point that we
knew what Spike protein did and that it
was a highly biologically active
molecule and therefore at the very least
if you think that your alteration of
that molecule has disarmed it the burden
of proof is very definitely on you it is
not misdis or mal information no maybe
it's Mal information by that absurd
definition but
it is not miss or disinformation to just
simply note that this High highly
biologically active molecule
which is cytotoxic was an unfortunate
choice for a therapeutic That was
supposed to make you healthier and in
any case I guess my point is we are now
years down the road from an episode in
which officialdum no doubt driven by The
Who CDC maybe the White House we don't
know decided to crack down on US
citizens biologists simply saying clear
things into a camera that we were not
allowed to say we are living in the era
of officially designated wrong think
true things have been designated wrong
think and we actually have powerful
forces going after citizens for simply
remarking on what is in front of them
and that is a terrifying place to be it
is and it reminds me too of something
else there's many other things that
should be on the list of what am I
actually concerned about on a day
designated Earth Day
um as opposed to the gimmicky do nothing
virtue signaling things like sign this
petition
uh things like the near
yeah
well Neo nicotinoid
um insecticides and uh the glyphosates
and the
um synthetic mRNA and meat and the
building roads and the Deep Wilderness
um
maybe stop making Franken viruses and
labs
how about that
well obviously I think that one's on the
list it's the top of the list because
the you know the self amplifying nature
of viruses means that this is not like a
pollutant it's far worse
um so that that is a uh a huge danger
and we have just suffered a massive
self-inflicted wound that if it is not a
wake-up call then we are unwakable so
yes clearly clearly we should be doing
that
um I also want to just say
the theme of our book is hyper novelty
we clearly have a pathology that is
built of hyper novelty and gain of
function research is one example of a
particularly potent way in which we do
inflict wounds on ourselves but
there are so many and one problem is
that we are
just simply addicted to the idea that
um progress is normal
normal and relatively comprehensible and
therefore if something seems like it
might be good let's do it and then when
we routinely find out that something
that we made a decent argument for
turned out to be bad we are we got to
stop being surprised by that yeah and
now I've been thinking about the label
progressivism
right which is something that I always
thought of myself as a progressive as as
did you and
I never ever imagined
the people who thought of themselves as
progressives
thought
anything labeled as progress is good
anything that has been done before is
bad
but that seems to be that that one-two
punch of idiocy seems to be the thing
that is masquerading as progressivism
now as opposed to
understand
diagnose and work hard to maintain that
which has been done before and which is
still working
and assess carefully and do not proceed
if you can't undo and employ the
precautionary principle
those things that might allow us to
become better in some important way in
the future that's the progress part
most of the ideas that most people have
aren't good the idea that all you have
to do is slap a label on it this is
progress and then we're going to say yes
well that's how you get to team loser
that's a really quick route to team
loser right there
is also true that we are playing a
different game now because of the way we
are integrated together it's one thing
if and this is you know the
conservatives have a bunch of stuff
right they are more reluctant about
changing things up just for the sake of
doing it and they are also obsessed with
choice
to the extent that some group of people
thinks that some new thing might be
great that's fine anytime Choice like
school choice
the choice to do or not it's just a
choice on its own there is a little
jarring because the usually when people
say choice in a political context they
mean exactly the thing the conservatives
are usually not interested in having
choices yeah what I really mean is
Liberty right and the point is
when you mandate a vaccine for the
entire human race you are taking a new
kind of risk right because the point is
if it turns out that you're a numbskull
and that That vaccine isn't a vaccine
and it isn't safe and it isn't warranted
then you haven't left anybody in the
group of people who
doesn't suffer the consequences
so it is you know this is also true with
externalities right you can say that
your pollutant isn't a problem and the
point is you know Europe because we
can't measure it doesn't mean you didn't
cause problems right and so you know
it's when you're doing something new
it's the precautionary principle when
you're eliminating something old it's
chesterton's fence these things belong
squarely in our thinking because we live
in a complex system and the chances that
we understand what's going to happen
when we add something or subtract
something are are very low until it's
been done which should also make us very
concerned about anything that we're told
everybody's gotta do the new thing or
stop doing the old thing or whatever
which I had two more things I wanted to
say before we close out here I have the
sense that's where we're headed one is
that my conversation this week with Mary
Harrington yeah
um I forgot to say something about top
of the hour rarely on this topic so she
lays out uh especially so she's got she
it's already out or she's about to have
coming out this book uh feminism against
progress
terrific highly recommend it and I have
not listened to your conversation yet
but she's terrific she is terrific and I
will say she was especially good I
always worry when somebody has written a
book I worry about us in this regard too
I think we've done well but when you've
written a book and you've laid out a
thesis and then something changes or how
good are you at acknowledging that
actually that book represented a
position in time but your your actual
position has has evolved
Mary was excellent on this front right
we actually had a honest-to-goodness
disagreement over whether or not
progress is real and should be expected
and I think we both enjoy the
conversation uh quite a bit and anyway I
really appreciate her willingness to
participate in a very live fashion you
know questioning stuff in a book that
isn't even out yet
um
so check out that podcast second thing
so it's about to come out yeah first or
something this week I think
um second thing I wanted to mention is
that last time which was not last week
but the week before I had two principles
on AI that I wanted to reveal and I
didn't even write them down because they
were so thoroughly ingrained in my mind
that I didn't think they needed to be
written down and then when we started
talking about them I forgot the second
one and I couldn't recover it until of
course we had turned off the cameras at
which point it came back to me but
anyway so I wanted to put it on the
table just so that it's there okay you
may want to back up a little bit the
first principle was in the AGI era which
is either here or about to Don
um you have to be agnostic about all of
the stuff that you think you know about
the way complex systems of people work
because the AGI future upends many of
those some of those things may continue
to be true but you can't assume it any
of them are you've got to check each one
so it's a sort of hyper agnosticism
about what you think you know that was
principle one
the second principle is that in dealing
with AI we have to treat it as a new
kind of life
right that the proper way to interact
with this thing is not to allow it to
fool you into thinking that because it
talks like a person that it is
person-like in some sense the answer is
we actually do not know in the same way
that if creatures walked off a spaceship
and they started speaking English you
could infer presumably they've been
listening to us they figured out how to
speak the language but you can't infer
anything you don't know if their friend
or Foe you don't know in what way they
conceptualize things so a
this is really a question of ethology
that is the study of creatures that are
not us that are not human be havior of
creatures right and yes the behavior of
creatures and that this is such an
entity and one other
I mean it's obvious but of course the
the one way that you're
the way that I immediately see that the
analogy doesn't hold is that organisms
that land here and walk off a spaceship
and start speaking to us are autonomous
don't aren't Downstream of us
well but it does hold because we
actually do not know in what way that
this is Downstream of us because we do
not yes we know that it was trained on
our interactions and our
products our language but we do not know
what the combinatorics do and I would
point out it's true but it would not
exist without us sure true so that's
that's just a a I'm not saying maybe the
manifestations of that are trivial
but maybe not that's perfect that's
principle one
we don't know you can't assume um but I
would point out I did uh caught I did
not see the report but apparently 60
Minutes did a thing on AI in which they
covered the topic that
um an AGI large language model
responded to a prompt in a language it
had not been trained on
or had not knowingly been trained on
they had not intended to train it I
think it was uh
uh Bangladesh
Bengali it responded wait it's about
Bangladesh or it's in the language it
responded in the language
um not and surprised its programmers
because they had not intended for it to
learn this it's obviously something
that's learnable and that they might
ultimately decide to teach it so this is
important for two reasons one that's
surprising right a child is never born
who speaks a language because there's a
process and so the point is our
inference about a process is necessary
in order for you to pick there's a child
in a family of English speakers suddenly
start speaking Bengal right exactly
right it's the height of absurdity to
imagine such a scenario the point
Bengali like I think so okay I don't I
don't know I I don't know either okay
but I think so
um but in any case the piece which I
still have yet to release my 2016 piece
posited this relationship
exactly flipped right my piece argued
that here's a tractable problem here is
a way to train a computer to translate
fluently between languages in a way that
has never been accomplished by human
computer scientists in spite of billions
of dollars at stake uh possibly
trillions of dollars at stake in the
puzzle and yet children solve the puzzle
automatically
or they at least pick up language
automatically so my point was here's a
mechanism and I describe how you would
do it that would allow us to create a
computer that can translate between
language and I said oh by the way if you
do that what will come out of that is
Agi
right here we appear to have created AGI
and then what we've got is translation
into languages we didn't ask it to learn
right so anyway
tantalizing that that relationship seems
to exist to me anyway but anyway
principle one be agnostic about
everything you thought you knew about
human interactions because the way
humans will interact in the context of
AGI may be radically different and
second principle is treat it as a new
type of Life although you are right it
is not it is a product of
of us in the same way that you know DNA
life is the product of a prior RNA world
something like that
but treat it as a new kind of right in
life
aliens walking off a spaceship are an
entirely separate independent evolution
of life with different different
informational molecules that are driving
you know they don't they won't have DNA
right yep right
all right and of course neither does the
AI but
well you can have as much as it would
like
no it's Earth Day man come on all right
not today
hopefully if it's watching it will hold
off until it isn't Earth Day although
that's too low it's always Earth Day we
are going to formally declare it always
Earth Day to Stave off the AGI excellent
maybe that's our title for the week all
right
um all right I think we did it we did
that was live stream 170. it was live
stream 170. we'll be back in 15 minutes
for the Q a uh you can ask your
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com if
you want more or uh an opportunity to
interact a little bit in the chat with
us we're going to be doing our private q
a on my patreon at tomorrow it's Sunday
April 20th third at 11 A.M Pacific
um you can also um people are beginning
to get like questions are like oh I have
I have logistical this I want to send
you a thing both our websites have
mailing addresses listed on them and you
can also always email darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com and get logistical questions
answered but that's not the place to ask
questions for us to answer in the Q a
that's going to be at
darkhorsesmissions.com
okay we'll be back next week also uh in
addition to in 15 minutes until we see
you next we get to the ones you love eat
good food and by all means get outside
[Music]
foreign